a amm
[Música]
ah
nas proximidades da estação de volta
redonda entre a linha da estrada de
ferro central do brasil e eu venho
paraíba
o local oferecia sampaio trabalhadores e
operários deverão ser empregados somente
na preparação do evento na fundação que
construção dos grandes edifícios de
volta redonda o funcionamento da usina
virá mais de quatro mil operários
toda a direção de dezenas de técnicos
podendo concretizar-se toda certa
solidão dentro de três anos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o gol
[Música]
em volta redonda no estado do rio os
operários ocupam a companhia siderúrgica
nacional e entrou em greve à meia-noite
de hoje
[Música]
depois da greve de 84 outras
paralisações acontecerão sempre com a
intervenção do exército
mas como vinham soldados do batalhão de
barra mansa quer em sua maioria formada
por filhos de metalúrgicos nome
conflitos
isso até o momento de 1988 quando todo
esse cenário pacífico mudou
completamente o
[Música]
as tortas acesso foram chamados para
retirar os operários da siderúrgica
os grevistas e entraram em choque com
soldados e pedras
[Música]
o ataque
de fácil entendimento
a usina vai trabalhar com os que lá
estava
[Música]
eles queriam matar mesmo
ah ah ah
[Música]
an a
foi enterrado hoje à tarde em volta
redonda no estado do rio o corpo de
valmir de freitas monteiro um dos três
operários da companhia siderúrgica
nacional que morreram nos conflitos de
ontem à noite entre metalúrgicos em
greve e soldados do exército e da
polícia militar
um silêncio pesado estava sobre volta
redonda no fim da noite era trégua de
madrugada
várias reuniões foram realizados os
enterros dos dois outros operários
william fernandes leite e carlos alberto
barroso serão realizados amanhã
houve ainda 38 feridos seis continuam
internados no hospital de volta redonda
o conflito começou no início da noite de
hoje o tesouro
eu sei o sonho de jesus que é o sonho do
rio onde ouvia barulho de bota e livre e
motor de jipe
hoje houve saxofone houve uma zabumba
ouvir o som da perna de pau bateu no
paralelepípedo e onde os senhores
estavam quando esse processo aconteceu
quando o parque da cidade mudou a forma
de o moodle agente protagonista dessa
cidade
os artistas da cidade estão armados de
narizes vermelhos
[Música]